es uno de los artistas más famosos del
mundo me llamo ai weiwei soy un artista
bordalás grandes cuestiones de nuestros
tipos
creo que podemos hacer mucho si abrimos
nuestros corazones y tratamos de
entender lo que significa ser refugiados
es el disidente chino más célebre no
puedo hablar estoy bajo una tradicional
fue perseguido por la policía que
destruyó su estudio en shanghái luego
encarcelado antes de verse obligado a
abandonar su país porque se sentía
amenazado
acabo de publicar un libro mil años de
alegría sí pero
estas memorias narran la vida de su
padre la suya propia y 100 años de
historia china
está aquí en francia porque sus memorias
fueron traducidas al francés
decidió escribirlas para su hijo cuando
fue detenido por las autoridades chinas
en 2011 porque tomó esta decisión
cuando me dijeron que podría permanecer
en la cárcel más de 10 años me surgió
una pregunta urgente y mi hijo cuando
salgan no me reconocerá no sabrá
realmente lo que me pasó a mí oa su
abuelo
así que me dije si salgo tengo que
escribir para dejar un rastro
observé corte
al igual que en esta celda que el mismo
recreo ai weiwei estuvo recluida en una
prisión china durante 80 días en 2011
con dos guardias que lo vigilaban día y
noche
mientras tanto el mundo entero
protestaba por su liberación pero usted
no lo sabía cómo afrontó esta situación
uno no puede hacer nada no hay abogado
no puede llamar a su familia para
decirles dónde está me dije que estoy en
sus manos pueden hacer lo que quieran
conmigo
porque las autoridades chinas le temen a
usted y al arte
buena pregunta en china no hay voces
discordantes el silencio es total
por lo tanto cuando alguien se hace huir
es percibido inevitablemente como una
voz que se opone las reglas
tienen miedo de voces como la mía que
son subversivas
porque yo no tengo miedo y mucha gente
escucha
gran parte del libro trata de su padre
el mundialmente famoso poeta chino el
año que usted nació él fue desterrado y
enviado un campo de trabajo usted creció
en el exilio viviendo en una trinchera
que a su padre lo obligaron a realizar
trabajos forzados tuvo que usar un gorro
de burro limpiar los baños públicos no
le permitieron leer ni escribir tuvo que
quemar sus libros qué efecto tuvo esto
en usted
pasó unos veinte años en el exilio
esa fue nuestra vida nadie pensó que el
partido comunista nos dejaría volver a
vivir como seres humanos normales
así que a partir de esta experiencia que
viví entiendo la condición humana
de lo anormal y mala que puede llegar a
ser la sociedad
puede ser la oscuridad total
hoy su vida es totalmente diferente es
un artista reconocido internacionalmente
vive con cierta comodidad como concilia
estas dos partes tan diferentes de su
vida
cuando miro atrás si mis primeros años
fueron muy duros incluso inhumanos pero
eso me enseñó muchas cosas y hoy soy
famoso sí
pero sigo siendo muy prudente con eso
de qué se trata exactamente qué
significa ser reconocido y cuál es mi
responsabilidad
hasta qué punto debo seguir defendiendo
los derechos humanos y la libertad de
expresión
el título de su libro está inspirado en
un poema escrito por sus padres que
evoca las ruinas de una ciudad antigua
mil años de alegrías y penas de los que
no queda ni el menor rastro hombres que
viven disfrutan de la vida no esperen
que la tierra los recuerde porque este
poema es tan importante para usted
creo que los poemas revelan una especie
de verdad útil
y sabe que nuestra lucha humana es
temporal
pero si nos hacemos tanto daño entre
nosotros o al planeta tierra afirman
los humanos pueden desaparecer sin dejar
rastro
creo que esta es una elección importante
que nuestra vida es preciosa y no eterna
así que tenemos que encontrar la manera
de que tenga sentido
cuando china se abrió en los años 80
usted se fue a vivir a nueva york y
vivió en esa ciudad durante 12 años como
cambio esta experiencia su visión del
mundo
me emocioné pero también perdí mis
ilusiones sobre occidente sobre el
capitalismo extremo y su frenético
estilo de vida
buscaba un destino después de salir de
china
pero no sentía que pertenecía a esa
sociedad
así que volví a ser un solitario
se sintió más libre libertad es una
palabra que se utiliza a menudo si uno
es libre de mal policía que lo busque
puede ver a quien quiera a la gente no
le importa pero el hecho de que a la
gente no le importe es el problema la
gente está completamente aislada ya
nadie le importa usted estaba nueva york
en
1989 cuando tuvieron lugar las protestas
de la plaza de tiananmen en su libro
escribe los jóvenes chinos de hoy no
saben nada en absoluto sobre las
protestas estudiantiles de la plaza de
tiananmen en 1989 y si lo supieran
probablemente no les importaría porque
aprenden a ser sumisos incluso antes de
haber adquirido la capacidad de dudar y
discutir las ideas recibidas como
lograron los chinos borrar este acto
creo que el gobierno chino es el que más
éxito tiene la hora de falsificar la
historia
heitinga
ocultar hechos o borrar pruebas
lleva décadas haciéndolo
con películas sobre la difícil situación
de los refugiados pero también sobre la
pandemia del 19 la obra de ai weiwei se
ha convertido en una búsqueda de la
verdad y la libertad en 2008 se propuso
identificar a más de 5000 niños que
murieron en el terremoto de sichuan
y usted dice que fue en ese momento
cuando pasó de ser un artista a una
activista como este doble compromiso
ante la educación siempre le dice a uno
que se convierte en artista porque tiene
talento en el dibujo o en la pintura o
en la escultura
pero esto al final es muy limitado para
tratar solo le sirve a uno
beteta
pero cuando me di cuenta de que al hacer
oír mi voz estaba sintiendo el público
my voice
entonces me di cuenta de que mi talento
era mucho más poderoso para luchar y
defender la justicia
gasteiz
por ejemplo usted lleva mucho tiempo
pidiendo la liberación de julian assage
lo visitó en la cárcel se manifestó en
contra de su extradición a eeuu lanzó
una campaña en las redes sociales
llamada one for all rights con el
objetivo de defender la libertad de
prensa ve usted similitudes entre las
acciones de denunciantes como julian
assange edwards snowden y chelsea man en
contra sus gobiernos y su propia
experiencia de resistencia contra las
autoridades chinas
wang hay paralelos pero también hay
diferencias cuando hablé con las
autoridades chinas occidente se presentó
como una especie de héroe
phantom ones
eduard snowden chelsea manning fueron
presentados como criminales
a pesar de que llegaron a sacrificar sus
vidas de alguna manera
para proporcionar información crucial
sobre los crímenes de los cubrieron su
occidentales
lo que hicieron fue proporcionar
información como lo haría cualquier
periodista
aunque muchos medios de comunicación en
accidente no siempre apoyan estos
valores cruciales del periodismo
i
su padre fue enviado a un campo de
trabajo en la región de xinjiang donde
hoy en día los uigures son enviados a
campos de trabajo en algunos países
occidentales han calificado esto de
genocidio cual es la responsabilidad de
occidente sobre los derechos humanos en
china y
occidente debe considerar los derechos
humanos como el único valor que debe
proteger un estado
en una religión una ideología al súper
carácter y defenderlo sin encontrar
nunca excusas para no hacerlo
occidente tiene ponderaciones para votar
y selecciona sus causas en función de lo
que pueda servirle
pero muchos actos para los que cometen
otros gobiernos incluso occidentales
son totalmente ignorados
china no va a aceptar este tipo de
acusaciones y no es así como funciona
debido a la preocupación por los
derechos humanos en china algunos países
organizaron un boicot diplomático a los
juegos olímpicos de invierno y no
enviaron representantes oficiales esto
hace una diferencia deberían los atletas
boicotear también debería occidente
haber hecho más para evitar que se
realizarán estos juegos
al andar
durante unos días se hablará de esto
pero todos sabemos que china tiene el
apoyo de occidente
simplemente porque a través de la
globalización en occidente voy a china
con una especie de beneficio
del
occidente le gusta trabajar con
regímenes autoritarios
que no respetan los derechos de los
trabajadores ni los derechos humanos
esta es una situación ideal para
occidente
nunca quisieron que china se convirtiera
en una democracia que fuera como el
perdieron esta auto maldad
es todo muy hipócrita este wildcat es
una broma no se boicotea una competición
deportiva hay muchas otras cosas que se
podrían hacer
en todas las grandes multinacionales
tienen sucede en china y obtienen
enormes ganancias
porque no boicotea ellas a china
porque boicotear una competición
deportiva
es ridículo de seda
y china sólo lo ve como un signo de
debilidad de occidente y que ya no es
capaz de defender sus propios valores
también está el tema de la gestión del
cob y de los juegos olímpicos china
tiene una política de 'cero coin usted
realizó un documental sobre este tema y
otros sobre el sars en 2003 como juzga
la política de china sobre esta pandemia
esta política es ridícula
no se basa en consideraciones
científicas rojas
no se basa en la racionalidad sino en
consideraciones burocráticas y militares
que juegan con la psicología de la gente
para intimidar a toda la sociedad
eso es lo que hacen siempre pero ahora
es más extremo porque controlan los
datos personales de todo el mundo y lo
vigilan todo
así que ya no se es un ser humano sino
una especie que se puede controlar
usted ha dicho en el pasado que todos
pagaremos el precio de una china más
poderosa qué quiere decir con esto
china sabe que occidente no puede
permitirse romper con ella
alemania ha dejado claro que su futuro
industrial depende de china
francia el reino unido y sus
funcionarios cuando van a china
se puede ver lo mucho que les gusta ir a
hacerle el juego al emperador para
obtener contratos
de combate o lo que sea
pero china es mucho más fuerte en este
juego el del dinero
china es rica poderosa puede tomar
decisiones rápidamente
ai weiwei hoy en día vive exiliado en
portugal salió de su país cuando le
devolvieron el pasaporte en 2015 no fue
desterrado volverá
todavía quiero volver a china puedo
volver mañana si quiero pero nunca podré
estar seguro de volver a salir puede que
nunca vuelva a saber tengo
como una estrella en el cielo o un árbol
en el campo me ayudó a dirigir mi barco
en una dirección que era totalmente mía
esto es lo que escribe sobre su padre
que habría pensado el de su éxito no
creo que a mi padre le hubiera importado
puede que ni siquiera le gustarán las
obras de arte y eso está bien somos
representantes de dos generaciones muy
diferentes que tienen que enfrentarse a
problemas muy distintos
este libro está dedicado a su hijo que
imagina para el más alegría o más penas
mi hijo cumplió 13 años hace unos días
está lleno de energía es optimista tiene
opiniones sobre el mundo que lo rodea lo
que me hace muy feliz pero eso no
impedirá que me aunque esté creciendo de
un modo muy diferente al mío igual de su
abuelo
muchas gracias ai weiwei gracias